tu vas aller au cou mais il fait une
promesse 1
[Musique]
on veut voir
lui
aussi je trouvais amusant faire les
travaux pour reconstruire des jeunes
comme toi là tu es costaud comme tous
mes soit pas résister davantage mes
parents faire des bêtises d'un doji sous
les braquages se fout
ma vie
mais les knicks
[Musique]
il
emmanuel macron c'est le président de la
france et quand on fait un doigt
d'honneur au président de la république
quelque part c'est la france qui est
abîmée et on a l'impression qu'il y
prend un espèce de plaisir narcissique
et louise cette image me choque
[Musique]
ce jeune dont parlait quelques minutes
après on était en bas au milieu des
immeubles
il ya une dame qui est venu me voir et
elle m'a dit ma fille est handicapée et
voudrait vous embrasser elle était très
loin
déjà très en retard je pouvais pas le
faire j'ai pris les deux jeunes celui
qui sortait de prison et celui qui
manifestement a fait ce geste accès lui
et en ses ap huit fait des études et
veut avoir un travail
j'aurais dû aller chercher la petite île
ont porté la petite est loin apporter
pour que je t'embrasse
il faut arrêter de penser que dans notre
jeunesse parce qu'elle est d'une
certaine couleur parce qu'elle a un
moment fait des bêtises et rien à tirer
celle inverse
moi mon rôle c'est de chercher dans
chaque jeune de la république ce qu'il a
de bons à offrir ils n'ont fait et ces
deux gamins qui sans doute ont fait
plein de bêtises des choses très
répréhensibles ont beaucoup ennuyé la
vie du quartier sans doute et ses deux
gamins parce que je leur ai demandé si
on était capable de faire ça parce que
je les ai regardés avec confiance parce
que je les ai respectées
c'est ça la république
on tirera rien des discours de haine et
donc ce qui fait que je me suis battu
pour être élu face à marine le pen
je suis là aujourd'hui c'est parce que
j'aime chaque enfant de la république
quelles que soient ses bêtises parce que
bien souvent parce que c'est un enfant
de la république il n'a pas choisi
l'endroit où il est né